bonjour à tous je m'appelle sophie et je
suis né en 1992 dans le département le
moins peuplé de france la lozère alors
je réponds tout de suite à la première
question que tout le monde se pose oui
nous avons l'eau courante et
l'électricité en lozère je plaisante
mais je ne compte plus le nombre de fois
où on m'a fait cette petite blague
on a même internet et on s'intéresse à
la digitalisation des entreprises est la
digitalisation des entreprises car oui
je réponds à la deuxième question que
tout le monde se pose nous avons des
entreprises en lozère et c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi je suis très fier
aujourd'hui en tant que petit lozérienne
de venir présenter ce tedx pour vous
parler de la prochaine révolution
digitale
alors quand on parle de digitalisation
les premiers terme qui me viennent à
l'esprit sont rapidité adaptabilité
télétravail liberté du le travail
opportunités mais aussi
j'accompagne depuis quelques années
maintenant tous types d'entreprises dans
leur transformation numérique alors que
toutes ces notions n'existait pas pour
beaucoup d'entre vous il ya seulement
quelques années alors je dis beaucoup
d'entre vous parce que bon si j'observe
la salle vous avez tous l'air
relativement vue enfin plus de 20 ans
quoi
tout comme moi tout comme vous je suis
de la génération qui n'est pas né avec
elle qui s'est retrouvé téléporter avec
un tas d'outils digitaux en l'espace de
quelques années je me souviens encore du
premier ordinateur de la famille avec
l'arrivée d'internet dans ma petite
campagne un bon gros vieux macintosh je
devais avoir 12 ou 13 ans et croyez moi
c'était un sacré événement alors
qu'aujourd'hui les enfants naissent
presque avec une tablette ou un
smartphone dans la main
en parlant de smartphones en mots
froment premier iphone pour mes 19 ans
et mon départ pour big apple new york là
bas je travaille au sein du service
communication d'une grande maison bijoux
au coeur de la fashion week
et devinez quoi on n'utilise pas encore
les réseaux sociaux le service
comptabilité entassent la paperasse et
pas de trace de logiciels de gestion si
ce n'est excellent nous sommes pourtant
en 2012 et puis je rentre en france
termine mes études et rentrer enfin sur
le marché du travail en 2015
je suis embauché par une agence de
communication digitale en tant que chef
de projet et c'est là que tout bascule
on me parle alors crm cms réseaux
sociaux je me forme sur le tas il suit
débaucher seulement un an après par un
éditeur de logiciels de gestion en tant
qu'experte e-commerce si vous dire à
quel point les compétences manquent dans
le secteur
là on me parle alors le rp pic datablog
cheikh intelligence artificielle
logiciels saas et j'en passe
côté individuel les réseaux sociaux ont
pris le pouvoir
les jeunes de ma génération vont dans un
restaurant parce qu'ils y installe g abl
d'ailleurs tu n'es pas instagram as tu
n'as pas d'amis enfin disons que tu es
obligé d'avoir des potes en vrai et que
tu ne peux pas accéder au nirvana
d'avoir des follower par midi
alors vous allez vous dirai cela vous un
petit peu vieille du haut de ses 29 ans
avec de l'expérience mais pas du tout ce
que je veux vous illustrez en vous
racontant tout ça c'est que nous avons
dû en tant que citoyen mais aussi
entreprises nous adapter à des outils
digitaux qui sont devenus la norme en
l'espace de quelques années
alors si je suis là aujourd'hui c'est
justement pour vous parler de cette
boîte à outil extraordinaire qu'est la
digitalisation comment l'aborder mais
aussi comment la comprendre dans un
monde qui va de plus en plus vite alors
comme moi vous avez connu le papier
carbone le fax ils les mails et les
réseaux sociaux le téléphone portable
l'ordinateur portable et enfin la
tablette
d'ailleurs la tablette parlons-en vous
êtes peut-être dit comme moi est ce que
ça va vraiment marcher ce truc c'est
moins pratique qu'un ordinateur portable
c'est plus gros qu'un smartphone et ça
rend pas dans la poche
et puis si ça a marché parce qu'il y
avait une pomme dessus
vous avez ensuite connu et la signature
électronique et puis les qr codes très
pratique pour les passer à me taire les
objets connectés pour que votre frigo
vous rappelle de passer commande chez
chronodrive que votre compteur linky
vous rappelle aussi que votre facture a
triplé avec l'arrivée de tous les
nouveaux appareils numériques
et enfin la réalité augmentée pour que
vous puissiez chercher des pokémon dans
la rue
alors tout ça c'est merveilleux et
pourtant d'entreprise la digitalisation
et ben ça coûte une blinde parce que
c'est une constante recherche entre le
besoin des utilisateurs et les outils
digitaux la mise en place des outils
digitaux qui répondent
alors je suppose que vous avez tous vu
titanic eh bien figurez-vous qu'on
assiste déjà aux naufrages de
l'entreprise traditionnelle face à
l'entreprise digital en effet les
entreprises qui ont décidé de rester
dans le monde physique ont de plus en
plus de difficultés alors face à ce
constat deux options s'offrent aux
entreprises la première monte dans les
canots de sauvetage de la digitalisation
force et je me dis vitalise parce qu'il
faut se digitalise et alors je mets en
place des réseaux sociaux sans vraiment
savoir comment les utiliser un site
internet vitrine ou e-commerce
référencement sur google ou de l'impact
que cela pourrait avoir sur mes stocks
ou enfin un logiciel de gestion erp et
ou crm très coûteux sans investir dans
le projet
d'ailleurs en parlant de logiciels de
gestion aujourd'hui je vais vous révéler
le secret le mieux gardé des logiciels
de gestion
ce secret c'est lorsque vous mettez en
place un logiciel de gestion type ver p
la probabilité que cela se termine par
un échec et 2 50% lorsque vous mettez en
place un crm logiciels de gestion de la
relation client
la probabilité que cela se termine par
un échec et de 70% alors ces chiffres
ils sont réellement dramatique dans un
contexte où le télétravail est devenue
la norme et où les outils de soutien aux
équipes sont devenus de véritables
facteurs de survie des entreprises
alors fort heureusement il y à l'idée
inverse celle de monter dans le fast
boot de la digitalisation
réfléchit c'est le moment d'appliquer ma
vision de chef d'entreprise utiliser
cette boîte à outil extraordinaire
qu'est la digitalisation pour me
différencier
alors on pense souvent à tort que la
digitalisation elle n'est faite que pour
les grosses entreprises alors qu'en
réalité tout type d'entreprise peut se
digitalise est alors quand une
entreprise se digitalise qu'est ce
qu'elle achète bien n'achète pas
simplement un site internet ou un
logiciel de gestion elle achète un
entonnoir de conversion efficace et des
processus performant
cependant et comme je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure avec les taux d'échec
d'implémentation des logiciels de
gestion
la digitalisation on comprend qu'on
prend encore de nombreuses barrières est
les frais parfois la digitalisation du
monde qui nous entoure ne cesse de
s'accélérer et la crise du colis de 19
ans n'a été en véritable catalyseur
alors aujourd'hui les compétences sur le
marché elles sont rares très coûteuse
les solutions qui sont proposées elles
sont peu adaptable peu évolutive de plus
en plus de solutions packagées voit le
jour mais c'est à l'entreprise de
s'adapter aux logiciels alors que ce
devrait être l'inversé
et c'est là qu'intervient la révolution
dont je suis venu vous parler
aujourd'hui
enfin elle a pris son temps mais je vais
vous expliquer cette révolution
technologique elle s'appelle le nos
codes
alors quand je dis que c'est la
révolution du futur j'ai un petit peu
omis de vous expliquer que ça existe
depuis très très longtemps mais à ma
décharge le micro-ondes a été inventé
par l'armée américaine bien avant que
celui ci arrive dans vos cuisines et
pourtant quand tout le monde sait bien
l'utiliser c'était une vraie révolution
alors en fait l'idée du code elle est
aussi vieille l'idée nos codes elle est
aussi vieille que l'idée du code parce
que les programmateurs et les
développeurs ils se sont très vite dit
que ben
le code c'est super chiant
en effet tu écris des lignes que tu
transformes 0 et en pour la machine tu
compile tu testes si toutefois sa marche
et physiquement dur compile turé
critelli et ainsi de suite c'est pas fun
fun
c'est pas très rapide et surtout c'est
très cher
alors tout de suite il y en a qui se
sont dit que ça serait bien de faire des
choses sans programmer et maintenant
après quelques années
ces technologies sont enfin mature alors
pourquoi vous compreniez un petit peu
mieux ce que c'est l'idée d'une au code
je vous dirais que vous êtes tous un
petit peu dé monsieur jourdain d'une au
code vous en avez tous déjà plus ou
moins fait sans le savoir si vous avez
stocker de la donner par exemple dans
excel pour le transformer en tableur ou
un graphique vous avez fait d'une au
code si vous avez créé un site internet
ou modifier un site internet via weeks
wordpress et bien vous avez fait d'une
au code c'est pas très technique c'est
beaucoup plus fun c'est plus rapide et
surtout c'est moins cher
et je ne suis pas la seule mois sophie
la petite lozérienne à dire que le nom
code c'est la révolution du futur en
effet l'agent skarner qui est une
référence dans le secteur du digital a
annoncé que d'ici 2024 64% des logiciels
créés dans le monde implanté dans le
monde se réfèrent grâce aux technologies
nos codes
alors pour les entreprises qu'est ce que
ça change et bien c'est enfin
l'opportunité de gagner cette course
effrénée entre le besoin des
collaborateurs des utilisateurs en
entreprise et la mise en place de ces
outils digitaux c'est enfin
l'opportunité de mieux se comprendre
parce que oui moi des développeurs et
des programmateurs j'aurais côtoyé
manager de nombreux ces dernières années
et il faut reconnaître que si les hommes
viennent de mars
femmes viennent de vénus
par les développeurs eux viennent de
vega s'est pas toujours très facile de
se comprendre
je plaisante trêve de plaisanterie je
vais vous donner un bel exemple de mise
en place grâce à un système nos codes
d'un système à des fins citoyens en
effet la ville de new york à proposer
une application gratuite destinée à ses
citoyens
afin de donner des informations
relatives à l'épidémie et permettant
ainsi aux autorités de donner presque en
temps réel et d'identifier presque en
temps réel les quartiers et les clusters
les plus touchées de la ville cette
application elle a été déployée en 72
heures avec zéro lignes de code
de mon côté avec trois collègues en
l'espace d'une nuit nous avions proposé
au ministère de la santé en applicatifs
permettant d'interconnecter l'ensemble
des hôpitaux de france et ainsi éviter
aux personnels soignants en tape coup de
fil inutile pour trouver des lits de
réanimation
disponibles
tout ceci illustre que le nom code il
n'est pas seulement destiné aux
entreprises mais peut aussi être utilisé
à des fins citoyenne ou dans un cadre
public et je suis convaincu que ces
nouveaux systèmes
permettent ouvre de nombreuses
opportunités à nos sociétés permettent
une meilleure liberté d'entreprendre et
une meilleure égalité des chances en
effet tout citoyen ou entreprise s'ils
le souhaitent et des heureux d'offrir un
service en vue d'améliorer son quotidien
ou celui des autres est aujourd'hui
grâce à ses technologies en mesure de le
faire le nos codes il est accessible à
tous et il est moins coûteux
les entreprises aujourd'hui non plus à
s'adapter un logiciel c'est le logiciel
qui s'adapte à l'entreprise alors la
digitalisation est là de lever de
nombreuses barrières l innovation et si
on sait l'exploiter nous offre
aujourd'hui davantage de liberté pour ma
part je suis retourné vivre dans ma
petite campagne au beau milieu d'un
hectare de terrain où j'ai installé mon
bureau et je ne travaille pas en haut
d'un building
les technologies nos codes
il arrivait de la fibre dans la petite
campagne nous offre aujourd'hui aussi
une opportunité une ouverture vers une
démocratie digital
merci